je vous lisais en titre le bio en pleine
crise de croissance alors que les ventes
n'avaient cessé d'augmenter ces
dernières années voilà le secteur lui
aussi rattrapé par l'inflation plus si
c'est ni pour cent en moyenne résultat
les consommateurs retournent au
conventionnels seul éclaircit la vente
directe vous voyez ce reportage entre
Chinon et Saint-Genou de Sarah
ton magasin bio Adrien Robin ne peut que
constater la hausse des prix voilà ce
produit là qui a 4,50 maintenant
il était à 4,22 en 2022 donc il a
augmenté on a une augmentation à peu
près 6 à peu près 6 et demi pour cent
qui correspond à la moyenne c'est
vraiment l'exemple type de la moyenne de
l'augmentation sur le magasin en fait
une augmentation que le gérant a tout de
même tenté de freiner mais la situation
est devenue économiquement intenable on
a essayé le plus longtemps possible de
de la réduire en proportion c'est à dire
s'il y avait un produit qu'augmenté de
10% on a essayé de pas l'augmenter de
10% des paniers moins remplis et une
fréquentation en baisse les clients
boudent le bio depuis 2022 20% de
chiffre d'affaires en moins alors des
quadriens Robins croisent un producteur
ce qu'il inquiète c'est l'augmentation
des prix est-ce que dans un avenir
proche les prix vont augmenter un petit
peu ou sont reste sur une stabilité ou
les prix vont pas évoluer de façon
exponentielle ils vont toujours évoluer
pour la bonne raison qu'il y a une forte
et une forte augmentation des produits
périphériques
Eric chenafi
et vitic que d'autres par l'inflation
car il nécessite l'utilisation de
matières premières on a eu une
augmentation moyenne
en gros sur tout ce qui est emballage
environ de 58% et on répercute on
répercute à peine 10%
mais dans le secteur du bio tout n'est
pas sombre les maraîchers semblent s'en
sortir mieux que les autres directions
sans genoux depuis 2016 Sylvain le tuyau
cultive fruits et légumes de saison
l'agriculteur reste peu dépendant des
énergies ici le coût principal c'est la
main d'oeuvre ses prix sont restés
stables et sa clientèle aussi les
légumes sont un peu personnifiés si vous
voulez on nous associe on associe
l'équipe en associe notre mode de
production aux légumes qui sont achetés
et par ailleurs on fait aussi attention
au prix que l'on pratique on essaie
quand même de rendre les légumes bio
accessibles au plus grand nombre donc ça
permet aussi de fidéliser les clients ou
d'en attiré de nouveau si c'est certains
s'en vont si tous les producteurs ne
sont pas touchés par l'inflation tous le
sont plus ou moins par le réchauffement
climatique les pertes de production
pourraient s'intensifier au fil des
années